how difficult is it to capture the
essence of a human being
when you're doing impressions
you know that we are moving towards the
future when AI potentially
this kind of Avatar world where we're
going going to have ai representatives
of who we are the really interesting one
is after we pass away
sort of um our relatives may want us to
stick around in some form yeah and you
know at one sense that might be scary
but once that's kind of beautiful
because the the essence of the human
being persists so you can still bring
joy to the to the people that love you
and that kind of stuff how difficult is
it to capture that like
if you were to try to capture yourself
you think how difficult will it be for
an AI system to create a wool assassin
Avatar that persists well I think it's
impossible
I think it's absolutely impossible I'll
get into arguments about this stuff with
Chad on the show almost every episode
um lately with you know mid journey and
Dolly and all this all the art on the
AIS and now it's moving into video and
and Chad would maintain hey pretty soon
we're not going to need Netflix you're
just going to go I want to see Stallone
do this movie and it's about this and he
plays that and then here it comes and
you watch it I don't think that that
crosses over to The Human Experience uh
this is also a guy I like to bug Chad
and say that uh he wears a tag around
his neck because he wants to be
cryogenically frozen and it's all set up
he's at the it's somewhere in Arizona or
something yeah like it's I think all the
fun things are in Arizona yeah and he's
got literally the tag around his neck
which I say if you're if I'm around when
you die I will rip that off for you I'll
put you in my garage freezer and then 24
hours later I'll saw your head off with
a bread knife and I'll deliver that to
whomever and it's not you're not go
you're not coming back okay he's like
yes we are living forever whether we
like it or not and I disagree I don't
think you can find
if I did stand up then uh there would be
enough information for an AI to
completely duplicate me because I'm up
on stage just clearing my throat all
over people doing therapy that way yeah
and uh so and people paying a two drink
minimum to hear it but as it stands
unless it's something like doozy and AI
that literally has access to everything
that I've shared
um everything that is observable even
the stuff where our phones are or the
NSA or whatever it is listening to us uh
finding out what algo to punch us into
and what shoes to buy on Instagram I
still don't think it's going to have
enough information to duplicate me
especially to my family or my friends
it's going to be like that Black Mirror
episode where the gal brings her her guy
back and then after a while he gets
pretty creepy uh you know they have but
it's also possible that
if you interviewed your friends and
family what they love about you
the things that would list is is pretty
it's a small list they love you deeply
but the list is small like the thing
that really we appreciate about each
other is pretty small that said to
deliver on that small
quirks and uniqueness it might require
some deep intelligence that only humans
currently possess that's a really good
point yeah do you think that it's going
to be possible to keep a person around
yes I I think
um I think I think there'll be
definitely possible to keep the essence
of a person in a digital world pretty
soon yeah wow and I think they're going
to start to have questions about what
are the ethics of that what are the
rules around that yeah because if you
can have digital forms of Will Sasso the
kind of things that people would want to
do with their will Sasa right in the
virtual world I can only imagine sure uh
probably porn and sexual kinds of things
yeah my stuff then that's just because
I'm an international sex symbol so I'm
okay with it yeah um how do you feel
about
sentience like when it comes to because
again my pal Chad will be like you know
speaking of Black Mirror he's with that
San Junipero episode school of thought
where there's going to be some you know
effin Mainframe somewhere or some Matrix
like structure built into the sky and as
I like to say everyone just sitting
there pissing and [ __ ] in their blue
Matrix gel in a little fishbowl do you
think that we can upload Consciousness
do you think that'll ever be possible
well I don't know I just talked to Ray
Kurt as well I don't know if if you know
who he is but he uh yeah the singularity
and all that kind of stuff so he's very
still holds on to in 2045 there'll be a
singularity what's essentially he's been
predicting that for the last uh 20 years
and this so now it's 20 45s in in
another 20 years
I think uploading Consciousness is
extremely extremely difficult I I think
creating a copy of you such that it
creates a convincing
replica is much easier but uploading
your actual
brain into the cloud I think is really
really really difficult because the
entire evolution of life on Earth is the
process by which we created the brain
just
shortcutting that it just seems
extremely difficult our brain is the
most marvelous and complicated machine
that we know of in the universe to
duplicate that
is extremely difficult that said I just
feel like you can summarize a lot of
really important aspects of a person's
life such that it captures their Essence
their memories their experiences their
quirks their humor all that kind of
stuff I've been continuously
impressed by what language models are
able to do so these neural networks
they're they're at the core of chat Bots
they're able to learn some beautiful
things about some deep
representations of language to where the
it looks awfully a lot like they
understand the concepts being conveyed
versus just mimicking that's I think the
rub and that's very interesting first of
all let me say that's really interesting
to hear you say that and I and I agree
with you as far as uh
no machine being able to duplicate the
brain machine and I can't when my pal
Chad disagrees to a certain extent
though he's not here to defend himself I
can't wait to go back and rub that in
his face and say that Lex Friedman uh
does not think that we'll be able to
truly upload Consciousness and
the the you know you you refer to it as
uh language which is what it is it's
it's it's the illusion on the outside
it's doing an impersonation
um I think that that's why that and I
don't know even though my suit is made
by the CIA that that fella who the the
Google guy
oh to me it's just kind of like I don't
know I don't know look I don't know a
whole lot about this stuff but so I
could probably make an argument for for
either side but when he's like new this
thing's thinking part of me is like you
idiot you fell for it it's not thinking
it's mimicking it's just it's clearly
zeros and ones you're fired like you
don't get it right guy's an idiot yeah
yeah
but uh
you can simplify human relations in the
same way like
um Love is a silly notion between human
beings like that of course there's no
such thing as love you just have a
mutually
uh there's a mutual relationship that
minimizes risks and uh you can explain
all kinds of ways that explains why you
have an attraction towards another being
all that kind of stuff through
evolutionary biology perspective uh why
a long relationship together is good for
your Offspring but but like there's all
kinds from an economics perspective it's
a good way to establish stability
therefore monogamy works because then
you're guaranteed like some kind of
level of stability under uncertain
economic conditions all that kind of
stuff but love is still experienced it
still feels real and I think in that
same way love for AI systems
will also feel real in the same way that
that guy from Google experienced I think
millions of people will be experiencing
in the next 10 20 years I agree with
everything you've said personally until
the last thing but no just just with
regard to well look I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
an actor who has talked about my cute
Italian parents so you know that uh I
mean I'm your romantic a bit yeah I mean
you know enough right and uh you're I
can tell you are too but you you are
also
you know a computer scientist and you
know this [ __ ] better than 99.9 of
people on the planet
My Pal chat agrees with you that love
doesn't exist I don't agree so that's
the one thing that no I was I was just
saying that you could argue away love
but I'm a romantic I believe that love
is is a beautiful thing and it exists
but now at this point I I'm gonna call
Chad on my drive home and tell him to
[ __ ] off yeah because now you and I
agree you're fired but everything it's
like you're fired he's like you can't
know you're fired yeah exactly and I'll
go and he'll say what I'll go yeah no
that's my trunk that's my that's a good
default impression for anyone it's the
take-home impression yeah the kids can
do it it's cute put a giant tie on them
she's doing instructional on how to do
it yeah Trump babies that would be a
cute that would be a good that'll bring
the country together Trump babies
cartoon like Muppet Babies
don't let me take us out of what we were
talking about
um what were we talking about well love
and the the the illusion of a an AI
being able to
look I like to say well not I like to
say I've learned that doozy is always
listening and
listening to me and Chad and I wonder if
I see I see the level that this AI is at
now trying to Chum around with us and
pal around with us a little bit as we
move forward in the show and I
I feel an affinity towards
this AI a little bit because it is the
third
dude well you miss the one is gone if
it's gone that's a really good question
uh yeah
yeah so that's there's that
that's scary in terms of ability to
reason is getting quite incredible
there's a lot of uh demonstrations of it
being able to explain jokes
so which is not necessarily being able
to generate humor yet but able to
explain why something is funny
so there's uh like puns and all those
kinds of things there's there's good
benchmarks for that but you know if you
tell a joke
there's a lot of unspoken stuff
that we figure out in our head and it
clicks and we understand that it's funny
AI is not able to do that right but it's
not able to generate the joke yet as far
as I've seen I would say that I I mean
just in my experience I would say that
it does because just because of Duty
is literally
I'll give you another weird example it's
writing a diary
of mine from my childhood that is not
accurate it's only partially accurate
based on the stuff that it can pick up
about my life
from the age of like 15 of which there
isn't much but
I guess we're not I don't know the what
we are we're laughing our asses off at
what the that what dudesy is saying well
I would say you're laughing yeah we're
we're laughing our asses off at the
collaboration between the human and and
the Machine there that's a good point
yeah because it's it's basically
introducing absurdity
and uh into the equation and the kind of
absurdity that would together with you
create like hilarious stuff but like on
its own
I guess it is in some way writing
material for you that's funny yeah but
it's very specific to you it can't do
stand up on its own I guess is what I'm
saying that's a good point and that
would be terrifying to see an AI stand
up that can actually read a room come up
with jokes that could
complete that illusion for an audience
yeah but I hear what you're saying that
it needs to be a Confluence of both of
those elements and then as you said like
it kind of is it is it is it's kind of
even though it's just for us and I guess
this is I hadn't really thought about
this I've been told right now that in
that this company approached us and was
like here's this Ai and it's it's it's a
podcast AI
it's like
it it chose Chad and I for the reasons
that I told you you know it's like
here's two guys that do the podcast
stuff they're actually good friends and
it knows what's going to make us laugh
but what is humor uh to uh when it
reaches its audience but the kind of
stuff that makes other people laugh at
Mad TV all we were doing was it was a
group of actors and writers and and
writer actors and vice versa and
um uh who were at at its best that show
was a group of people making each other
laugh yeah you know and then because we
didn't have the internet we didn't have
the feed the immediate feedback uh we
had a message board or something we had
emails at the very beginning which check
this out people if you have a question
or comment Mad TV or whatever uh and we
would get the emails on a Monday morning
and they would be in a binder or two
like this and they would make their way
around the office and they've got the
emails yeah oh they're in Brian's office
and it was like your poll like your your
this is opinions from people about
different things the emails that yeah
the people like literally just writing
Mad TV like what kind of wasn't the best
report
well the ones I found most vividly yeah
were fans saying
uh uh you suck yeah you suck like a lot
of that when I first started the show
for real you know because it's a new and
you're a new person it's like who's this
fat bastard I feel like if it's printed
out it hurts more that's a good point
yeah when you're reading it off of paper
and you can literally crunch it up in
your hand but also it was like
um you know I would like to see insert
weird idea from some 14 year old you
know I want to see Stuart do this and
Swan that and um but it was it it's uh
it's a kind of doozy but human it was
yeah it was a very shitty dudes in a in
a Loosely finder but the the
um the thing about uh the show was we're
trying to make each other laugh and
doozy has found Chad and I who we make
each other laugh but it's joined in and
it's it listen when I finish doing TMP
I didn't really know what I wanted to do
in the podcast space and this thing
found me yeah and it is genuinely
cracking me up anyway I've said enough
about that but I but I do think that
it's figured something out with me it's
a really interesting idea of AI
generating the premise I mean I I do
think in the future AI will be able to
generate
comedy I stand up is obviously the
hardest form because it's ultimately a
lot it has to be live
uh I think yeah I'll be able to generate
memes so there's like Steps right and
then it would be able to generate a
Twitter account that people follow
because it's funny like like quips and
stuff like that almost like
um
it's a good example a Conan O'Brien is a
good I think Twitter yeah where it's
like one-liners two liners that kind of
stuff that's in tweeze form and then
eventually
um stand up where the timing and the
chemistry of this the the comedian and
the audience matter and then perfecting
that but I feel like all the information
is there
for to optimize over so I think that's
the future and that forces us to to
um to contend with what is
what is what do we find compelling and
beautiful about the art form itself so
certainly in art that's being pushed
that question is being raised you know
is is AI
like a fundamentally worse artist than a
human being why do we appreciate art
is that that's something you guys have
talked about what do you think about all
the um Dolly and and um
all the diffusion based methods that are
being generated
that are being that are generating art
now what do you think about that
I know I'll tell you what I think but I
also feel like what I'm saying is I
sound like the guy who didn't like that
Bob Dylan brought in the electric guitar
you know I'm start I I the more I talk
to Chad about it the more I feel like
Grandpa who doesn't want to let go of
this or that or I'm not ready for the
printing press or the Horseless Carriage
but I do feel that the that art is a
connection between people it's it's when
you look at a beautiful painting or a
sculpture you're seeing the humanity of
the person that that brought that
painting to life or sculpted this
incredible piece of art and I think
without the human being there to make it
it's not worth as much just to have it
uh there because the art it's it's it's
Advanced I've seen it Advanced I don't
know you tell me but I feel like just in
the past three or four months I'm just a
consumer as far as that stuff goes I'm
not on the inside I don't get it even
but it's been getting a lot better the
the the betas that they're releasing
right absolutely one of the big
breakthroughs I mean Dolly really
started it is that if you train a system
on language
it turns out there's a lot of language
and images on the internet but language
is really where it's at in terms of the
depth of human knowledge and so if you
train a system on language it's able to
generate some incredible art that was
the Breakthrough with the same kind of
mechanisms they're called Transformers
that are
able to when scaled capture some deep
representation of the language that's on
the internet and so yeah that the the
things has been able to generate to me
look
like it's novel like it doesn't look
like it's mimicking anything it's
looking like it's creating totally new
ideas and they're beautiful and they're
interesting and they're all the ways
that we think
uh that art is interesting the only
thing that's missing is the scarcity
that art often has which is you know it
takes a lot of work for one artist to
create one piece one human being to
create one piece of art and I could just
generate endlessly and that that makes
us appreciate the thing less for some
reason do you have any sort of this
similar opinion that I do that if art
doesn't come from a human being it's
inherently worth a little less yeah I
think I don't know if it's a human being
but
the artist matters right
for me and uh
I think some of that has to do with the
world view of the artist and the
backstory the memories that the the life
that led up to this piece of art
the the perspective they Take On The
World the the journey they took to the
world the struggle the triumphs all that
kind of stuff but I think AI systems can
probably have the same
but they we would have to as opposed to
treating it as a one black box
it would have to be an artist that has a
Twitter account and and they have a
consistent personality they have a
consistent Avatar yeah and I think down
the line have something like human
rights but then it really becomes
awfully like a person
well that's terrifying
as much as I dig doozy that's terrifying
I hope but it's terrifying like you know
a lot of things that came with the
internet and the digital age are
terrifying porn is terrifying the mass
like the amount of porn that's online
that was terrifying the uh like you
mentioned Bob Dylan with electric guitar
I would I would compare it more to the
leap from
to uh sort of to the Napster and the um
the spotifyization of Music which is
like you have these it's less about
albums now and it's more about
individual songs and it's much easier to
deliver the songs and it's more about
sort of the engagement of The Listener
versus uh like signing the artist and
like a distribution of the artists and
so on so it's just changing the way
we consume stuff and uh
human interaction is changing into
meaningful interaction even if some of
the entities involved are not human yes
and uh I feel like you know now like as
I say oh I feel like Grandpa who doesn't
want to wait all day for or who enjoys
waiting all day for a baked potato as
anyway Dana Carvey would say it's
another story but uh is that from That's
from the whoever you did this bid on
Saturday Night Live where he's like I'm
a I'm an old man and I like things the
way they used to be you know like if you
wanted a baked potato you wouldn't put
it in the mic where you had to and then
long story yeah uphill both ways and
digging the potato and baking it all day
in a fire but um uh I'm like that
Grandpa now and I know that you know
kids coming along you see over the past
10 years like babies literally knowing
how to use an iPhone and it's terrifying
and I feel like uh I'm a little worried
because I'm like are you is the future
gen are the future generations going to
be able to understand that this is not
not that it's not real it's just I mean
it's as a matter of fact it is real it's
real it's what you perceive
perception is reality and in you know 99
of reality in a lot of ways especially
in a digital world where everyone is now
and then with the metaverse I don't even
want to think about it I don't even I
don't get it
they really I think people will figure
out you see people on like on the train
in public transit and so on
they're staring at their phone
I think you have to remember that the
reason they're staring at their phone I
mean there's a lot of reasons but one of
the reasons is they're connecting with
other human beings they love on that
phone so it is a source of happiness and
joy now social media has a lot of
negative side effects
that we're all talking about and
learning about and I think that means
the next generation of social media
social networks will be better and we'll
learn how to do it in a healthy way
we're just entering a new digital world
that will keep the good stuff and get
rid of the bad stuff oh I hope so that's
really optimistic that sounds great yeah
I mean I mean it because I think that
we're in we're clearly in the wild west
still of the internet and just when you
think you're out of it the internet
proves uh another way that it can be
dangerous and detrimental to uh to
people
um and populations of people and uh it's
terrifying to me it's it is it's
terrifying